un lion gardé derrière de simples
clôtures une employée qui manipule un
alligator devant des visiteurs
ces images filmées l'année dernière en
Ontario par un organisme de défense des
droits des animaux révèle les conditions
de vie parfois dramatiques dans certains
eaux privés de la province
nous sommes à
ici la plupart des bêtes sont des
animaux de ferme mais on trouve tout de
même quelques animaux exotiques comme
des kangourous en Ontario les ou comme
celui-là pullulent il y en aurait une
quarantaine et ils sont très peu
réglementés selon des organismes de
défense des droits des animaux qui les
dénoncent depuis des années
peut ouvrir une mesure il en revient
donc aux municipalités d'émettre leur
propre règle la province elle envoie des
inspecteurs pour s'assurer du bien-être
des animaux
dans la province son organisme demande
carrément que ces établissements cessent
leurs activités
nous avons identifié des problèmes dans
chacun de ces dit-elle elle explique par
exemple que les cages sont parfois trop
petites et que des animaux qui ont des
besoins sociaux importants comme les
singes vivent parfois seuls en Amérique
du Nord le saut de l'Association des
aquariums et des ours représentent le
plus haut standard en matière de gestion
des soins animaliers en Ontario seul le
zoo de Toronto et l'aquarium
replaysé
on ne pourrait plus flatter les
lémuriens mais les gens adorent ça
dit-il il faudrait aussi que nous
clôture respecte leur standard ce qui
n'est pas le cas actuellement il admet
tout de même que la province doit en
faire plus pour assurer le bien-être des
animaux
parmi les outils il y en a de très bons
et de très mauvais dit-il et je pense
que le nôtre n'est pas mal du tout
signe que le débat sur les ou privés en
Ontario est loin d'être terminé ils sont
en train nous liamada
Oshawa